Palestinians in Gaza fired dozens of rockets at southern Israel,...
...and Israel launched air strikes in return,...
...a day after an Israeli incursion prompted deadly fighting in the enclave.
In Afghanistan, at least six people are dead...
...after a suicide bomber attacked a police checkpoint in Kabul,...
...near a demonstration against the government's failure to prevent...
...Taliban attacks in two provinces.
Rebel-controlled Donetsk in eastern Ukraine...
...announces the winner of leadership elections that were dismissed by Kyiv...
...and its international allies as a sham engineered by Russia.
In the US, at least 31 people are dead...
...as two wildfires rage at both ends of the state of California.
Finally from Australia, a court on Monday ordered a 50-year-old farm supervisor,...
...charged in a strawberry needle contamination case that sparked a major food scare,...
...to remain in custody until she next appears in court.